[Musik]
herzlich willkommen liebes publikum zu
einer neuen ausgabe von wissen macht ah
und damit herzlich willkommen ja heute
zu einem neuen video auf meine your kids
was auch sonst hier sind bereits im
titel und zwar schauen wir uns heute
gemeinsam deutschland - an
ich hoffe mal das wird lustig aymanns
wenn jemand auf ihren reservierten platz
sind
das ist auch besonders schlimme man
irgendwo im urlaub ist und dann am pool
liegen und dann hat einer sein handtuch
drauf liegen die albatrosse man weiß ja
nie in germany we don't have to go now
wie klatschen wie oberschenkel and
beautiful german bin ich der einzige der
mettbrötchen überhaupt nicht geil findet
ja you can say you
[Applaus]
das hat auch die allgemeine sache mit
der deutschen linguistik und zwar ist es
einfach so verdammt kompliziert im
englischen sagt man einfach immer warum
machen wir es so kompliziert niemand
immer noch niemand wirklich einfach
keiner keine person auf der ganzen welt
ahlmann schau mal was sich günstig bei
jeep das ist eins zu eins meinem mann
sind so beim abendessen jeder ist seines
glückes mit rotkohl und da kommen aber
auch kuba was hier geht sie bald ab wenn
train tickets in your country am markt
hilft wenn airplane ticket war die
traurige wahrheit ein mann sven
klimawandel immer näher kommt als wenn
benzin teurer wird ahlmann sven
tempolimit 130 diskutiert wird das ist
halt echt die wahrheit und was dazu halt
auch noch passt es dass hier die
deutsche autobahn dass nutella oder die
nutella das ist ja eher so eine
allgemeine frage also ich sage dass
nutella keine ahnung was ihr sagt
schreip schon mal gerne in die
kommentare
in israel company apologize after trendy
die second early and ever cross red
light and child is watching ich wusste
gar nicht dass das anscheinend nur in
deutschland irgendwie so gang und gäbe
ist also dass man einfach nicht über
eine rote ampel fährt ein kleines kind
irgendwie zu schaut weil man will ja
kein schlechtes vorbild sein trauma new
german seed exchange light bulb von
julia fischer
leider war das hier ist eine definition
von deutschland und zwar denkt jeder
einfach dass wir die fünfte zeit nur
bier saufen sind you know you germany oh
shit freunde ich höre noch immer die
drei fragezeichen und ich bin 23
jedes mal wenn ich autobahn fahre immer
die drei fragezeichen
das hier sind die artikel die es in der
englischen sprache gibt und dass hier im
vergleich dazu dies in der deutschen
sprache also die leute die englisch
sprechen habe nur das wird und wir
deutschen haben dafür 16 andere begriffe
seinen doppelnamen ob es sind auf
rumfahren running samt innova ist
umfahren greifen
das ist genau die sache die ich meinte
warum ist diese sprache so gott verdammt
schwer und bescheuert albans wenn sie
die fünf cent zurück wollen die sie hier
in der mittagspause geliebt
[Musik]
das bild wenn wir deutschen echt so
krass geizig
ja eigentlich schon heftig ipswich hallo
erst einfach so die wahrheit und hallo
erstmalig bei rewe vergesse waren
trainer aus band zulegen ahlmann
hinterher
das ist halt auch so ein deutsches ding
und zwar wenn man im supermarkt ist und
seine produkte von denen des hintermanns
trennen will stellt man ja so eine
kleine wand dazwischen das gibt es nur
in deutschland smalltalk letztes
passauer herr es ist halt einfach wieder
die wahrheit immer wenn man mit jemandem
smalltalk hält ist die erste frage immer
alles klar bei dir oder wie geht's dir
oder alles gut bei dir es ist immer eine
frage nach der gesundheit softshell
jacken im angebot bei aldi ahlmann ist
so die wahrheit ich glaube jeder kennt
das wenn die man irgendwie das haus
verlassen will man fragt willst du hin
bei all diesem angebot leute die sagen
ich will mich da nicht einmischen aber
dass männer mich eins zu eins an diese
james gegen tat die geschichte und will
mich da nicht einmischen aber ich bin
jean charles was seid ihr schwein ist
die lieblings süßigkeit von alban
kindern seit 1853
stimmt alter ich weiß nicht wie es bei
euch früher war aber ich habe immer als
wir an der wursttheke standen so eine
kleine scheibe fleisch wurst bekommen
als wenn ich sage ich mache keinen spaß
wegen des schönen instead of sale laut
das budget habe ich mich schon so häufig
gefragt wunsch wenn man angerufen wird
und man ans telefon geht warum sagt man
seinen nachnamen die person ja einen
anruf weiß doch wer man ist sonst würde
sie einen ja nicht anrufen können wir
allerdings nun auch schon zum letzten
ihm dass ich heute vorbereitet habe und
zwar das hier sagte kugeln oder googeln
also sagen tut mir alle das gleiche es
hört sich ja gleich an aber schreibt
dass kugeln oder googeln schränkten die
kommentare unter stadt solche videos
auch beende meine lieben freunde wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne einen daumen
hoch unter diesem video der abonniert
main kanal wird es noch kein teil der
lupo sein und wenn ja dann klingt ja
noch die glocke dann bekommt die
benachrichtigung sobald ich ein neues
video hochladen
[Musik]